the name's bond james bond
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul terrible intro as always
the mission impossible trailer is now
out i'm actually away today whilst this
is happening but someone's uncle might
have uh might have leaked the trailer
yesterday and give me give me time just
to film a quick reaction we're gonna be
doing what we did with the ob1 trailer
reacting to it watching it going through
it bit by bit and then kind of giving
you know an easter egg breakdown if
there are any easter eggs i hope you
enjoy it um if you do please hit the
thumbs up button also subscribe we're
going to be doing the thor trailer later
on so make sure you stay locked in the
channel that'll be a proper breakdown
but uh at the moment i just don't have
time to probably cover this but thanks
for bearing with me you're the best
quite low-key music
so it should have didn't even
enemy
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over oh he's back
this is our chance
to control the truth
the concepts
you need to pick a side
the rogue side
[Music]
[Music]
it's quite like low-key i know they're
doing quite big stunts i don't know if
the music or what
[Music]
girl got hit in the face
blasted in the face
seen that happen a couple of times
personally
[Music]
this channel is the worst
he's running he's running
this is quite a lot of mission
impossible one easter eggs
[Music]
he'd love i bet he was just doing that
anyway and they just had the camera
rolling
on the off chances tom cruise loves
doing stuff like that i think that ethan
hunt is the real the real person and and
tom cruise is just the mask he wears to
to be able to do all these stunts
pretty i mean pretty good trailer um
nice stunting up
you can probably tell i'm not sure if
the music choice was the right way to go
with it because it was quite
you know it was very
they have hype soundtracks with mission
impossible not even not even going down
the limb biscuit route just in general
that was quite the the music you know it
was quite low stated but
the stunts were really good um looks
good
shall we break it down what else are you
doing for the rest of the day come with
me
okay so there's there's a lot of desert
shots throughout this um it seems in the
trailer that is gonna be a big conflict
in the desert so yeah you've got this
these shots here where i'm guessing
that's ethan
difficult to tell
looks slightly shorter than the other
people around him so it
it might be tom cruise tommy if you're
watching this i'm sorry don't don't kill
me
um yeah and then we've got that key
there i think that pops up later on in
the trailer
um let's have a have a quick scan
through yeah so
my boy tom he's with hayley at well got
that key
oh what
yeah
so that's a little um
mission impossible one easter egg isn't
it when he does the sleight of hand when
he has the knock list
he goes about i got the knuckles it's
over here about over here someone might
put that clip on screen right now so
it's not just me sound like an idiot and
you've also got a lot of train chasers
as well
with um
max's daughter
uh obviously there was the the first
film
the the climax of that took place on a
train
so yeah they've got so much train stuff
going on here that i'm guessing
yeah and they've got the knife swipe as
well which i'm sure that was in the
first film as well so it looks like a
lot of it is going to be riffing on the
first film you also have people like kit
ridge here who you might recognize from
the first film
it looks like they're basically in the
in the movie they have that big scene in
the restaurant where
tom's
well tom is the mask so i wasn't
incorrect there but tom his whole crew's
been killed apparently he's the only
survivor he gets called and he realizes
that there's another team on the job kit
ridge is like like we've been searching
for the mole you are you're the only one
left tom so we know it was you tom
throws the the chewing gum the explosive
one off the the fish tank and that that
explodes and kit ridges is there with
them and it looks like they're having a
similar sort of conversation even the
shots look very similar where kit ridge
is sitting on one side and our boy tommy
is on the other so it's like again it's
kind of playing that up it doesn't look
like a restaurant this time but you know
it might be a modernist one quite like
those ones um yeah you've got this chase
through the desert again you've also got
ilse back um i don't know who hayley
atwell's playing i'm guessing there's
going to be a sort of love triangle
there
i'm sure at one point i saw that our tom
he was snuggling up with you sir and but
she's got an eye patch on here don't
think she's doing a solid snake
impression or big boss impression sorry
guys got that wrong again um and it i
think that's just so she has better aim
down the the telescope because if you've
got like both eyes open you know what i
mean it's going to distract from that
scope so
don't think she's gone blind so bit of
an easter egg there
and she's clearly shooting at this
convoy of horses and you can see someone
coming off there
then there's our tom so yeah that that
was him from the opening uh
okay so you've got a submarine there's
an explosion going off
you've got max's daughter can't remember
her name so we'll call her max 2.
great breakdowns already
yeah you know what from from mission
impossible i always get a lot of
uncharted vibes like the plane scene um
i always got massive uncharted vibes
from it this moment here i get a lot of
uncharted vibes as well you know i'd
know uncharted didn't invent fights out
in the desert but it's just what i grew
up on
got another great car chase um it looks
like they go from this bmw
through
i think there's a yellow
little yellow car
yeah that that looks like it pulls out
itself
wish someone had got me to pull out
and i wouldn't be in this mess um so
so yeah they're speeding around on that
look look i'm getting a lot of italian
job vibes here
so yeah really nice you know this isn't
the best breakdown i've ever done
but look when you've got moments like
this where he's running and i'm going
whoo he's running what what would you
want so yeah tom cruise obviously famous
for running in almost every film and
there's that shot from mission
impossible three where he runs he runs
about 20 miles an hour
for a good five minutes um and it looks
like they're kind of recapturing that
so yeah i you know what i'm quite
excited for it and what a great stunt to
end the trailer as well so it looks like
he rides up to the cliff
you say oh whoa whoa not uh not going
over there and then he's obviously he's
tom cruise
he decides i'm gonna do it well he's
really ethan hunt as we've discussed but
don't tell anyone that so yeah it goes
over the edge um reminds me a lot of the
opening of goldeneye that looks like
he's got a parachute on but i'm sure tom
well ethan i'm sure he did it for real
this time uh
whereas
i'm sure that was actually him whereas
p.s brosnan probably had a stuntman this
guy
i mean that's quite a big drop
i hope no one was below that as well it
looks like they're just driving loads of
things over cliffs in this movie
we've got the train going over the cliff
there
the carbon footprint on this film i tell
you they've got trains they've got
motorbikes they've got submarines
blowing up
but it looks really good i mean that
looks like a real shot is happening
there i don't think that's cgi and i bet
tom talked haley anyway like oh come on
it's going to be great
i mean i wonder if she's going to be his
other half in the movie hey cause the
last time i seen her she had an other
half as well hey
a bit of a doctor strange joke there
anyway i think i've kind of unpacked
most of that
there will be a better breakdown
somewhere out there on youtube but
you're at this point now so i've wasted
your time enough already
i really liked it yeah i thought i mean
the music could have been better but
going through a bit by bit and seeing
all the stunts seeing our tom running
miles by the looks of it there it all
looks really nice um i am quite a big
fan of the mission impossible series i
like that you know the movies they've
all kind of got their own distinct style
you've got the first one
which is like a
70s espionage thriller by brian de palma
you've got the second one which is a
john woo film and it's
not that good third one jj abrams he's
kind of course correct he's doing the
classic jj abrams he's course correcting
getting everything to where it should be
and then from there i just think they
just hit home run after home run um and
i am really really i'm really excited to
see this i'm not sure when it's coming
out but this is part one of a two-part
movie um
so yeah it's gonna probably gonna end on
a cliffhanger
imagine if they kill isla ilsa or they
kill ethan oh that would be crazy it
might kill luther
simon pegs back at least as well so yeah
that was the trailer what did you guys
think comment below and let me know and
uh yeah thanks for checking out the
video hope you enjoyed it not a very
good breakdown not something i'm proud
of personally but there's loads of much
better videos on the channel right now
that'll be linked on screen so
definitely go check them out and i hope
you enjoy the rest of your day hope i
haven't wasted too much of your time you
take care of yourself peace